this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer on the 24th of
May SpaceX launched a falcon 9 rocket
filled with 60 satellites into space
this marked the beginning of their
ambitious new project called StarLink
which aims to provide high-quality
broadband internet to the most isolated
parts of the planet while also providing
low latency connectivity to already
well-connected cities SpaceX aim to make
their broadband as accessible as
possible claiming that anyone will be
able to connect to their network if they
buy the pizza box sized antenna which
SpaceX is developing themselves this
launch of 60 satellites was just the
first of money SpaceX has 12,000
satellites planned for launch over the
next decade dramatically increasing the
total amount of spacecraft around
Earth's orbit this will cost SpaceX
billions of dollars so they must have a
good reason for doing so let's see how
this network will work and how it will
compete with existing internet providers
back in 2015
Elon announced that SpaceX had began
working on a communication satellite
network stating that there is a
significant unmet demand for low-cost
global broadband capabilities around
that time SpaceX opened a new facility
in Redmond Washington to develop and
manufacture these new communication
satellites the initial plan was to
launch two prototype satellites into
orbit by 2016 and have the initial
satellite constellation up and running
by 2020 but the company struggled to
develop a receiver that could be easily
installed by the user for a low cost
this delayed the program and the initial
prototype satellites weren't launched
until 2018
after a successful launch of the two
prototypes tintin a and B which allowed
SpaceX to tests and refine their
satellite design SpaceX kept pretty
quiet about what was next for the
Sterling project until November 2018
when SpaceX received approval from the
SCC to deploy 7,500 satellites into
orbit on top of the 4400 that were
already approved on May 24th the first
batch of production satellite
were launched into orbit and people
around the world quickly started to spot
the train of satellites moving across
the night sky this launch is a sign of
things to come
while this initial group of satellites
are not fully functional they will be
used to test things like the earth
communication systems and the Krypton
thrusters which will be used to
autonomously avoid debris and deorbit
the spacecraft once it has reached the
end of its life cycle let's look at
these functionalities first we have
explored how ion thrusters work in the
past which you can watch for more detail
but essentially they use electric
potential to fire ions out of the
spacecraft to provide propulsion Zenon
is ideally used because it has a high
atomic mass allowing it to provide more
kick per atom while being a nurse and
having a high storage density lending
itself to long term storage on a
spacecraft
however SpaceX opted for Krypton as
Xenon's rarity makes it a fair more
expensive propellant this ion thruster
will initially be used to raise the
Starling satellites from their release
orbits of 440 kilometers to their final
orbital height of 550 kilometers they
will also be used in conjunction with
the onboard control momentum gyroscopes
located here and the US government space
debris collision prediction system to
allow the satellites to adjust their
orbits to dodge collisions which we have
also spoken about in more detail in a
previous video when the satellites have
reached the end of their service life
they can then use the same attitude
controls and thrusters to deorbit the
satellite SpaceX have included all the
necessary hardware to minimize space
debris risk in their Federal
Communications Commission approval
application they claim that 95% of the
satellite will burn up on re-entry with
only the ion thruster internal structure
and silicon carbide components standing
a chance of survival those silicon
carbide components are likely to survive
as they are essential materials for the
operation of lasers and thus have an
extremely high melting point of two
thousand seven hundred and fifty degrees
which brings us to our communications
abilities the primary function of the
satellite SpaceX have been tight-lipped
on many of the details
the satellite but thanks to the FCC
filing we know that the satellites will
contain 5 1.5 kilograms silicon carbide
components which indicates that each
satellite will contain five individual
lasers these lasers like our fiber-optic
cables here on earth will use light
pulses to transmit information between
satellites transmitting with light in
space offers one massive advantage over
transmitting with lies here on earth
however the speed of light is not
constant in every material in fact light
travels 47% slower in glass than in a
vacuum this offers StarLink one huge
advantage that will likely be its
primary moneymaker it provides the
potential for lower latency information
over long distance in simpler terms
let's imagine this as a race between
data packets a user in London wants the
new adjusted price for a stock on the
Nasdaq from the new york stock exchange
if this information were to use a
typical route let's say through the AC
to cable which has a return journey of
about twelve thousand eight hundred
kilometers to make through our glass
fiber optic cable in a vacuum light
travels at a speed of 299,792,458 meters
per second the speed of travel in glass
depends on the refractive index and the
refractive index depends on the
wavelength but we will take the
reduction as 1.47 times slower than the
speed of light in a vacuum
this means the data packet will take
roughly 0.063 seconds to make the
round-trip and thus has a latency of
0.06 three seconds or sixty two point
seven milliseconds with the additional
steps that add to this latency like the
conversion of light signals to
electrical signals on either end of the
optical cable traffic queues and the
transfer to our final computer terminal
this total time comes out at about 76
milliseconds figuring out the latency
for StarLink is a lot more difficult as
we have no real world measurements to go
by but we can make some educated guesses
with the help of Mark Hanley a
communications professor in University
College London the first source of
latency for
StarLink will be during the up and
downlink process where we need to
transfer our information to and from
earth we know this will be done with
phased array antenna which our radio
antenna which can control the direction
of their transmission without moving
parts instead they use destructive and
constructive interference to control the
direction of the radio wave each
satellite has a cone beam with an 81
degree range of view with an orbit 550
kilometres each satellite can cover a
circular area with a radius of 500
kilometers at SpaceX's originally
planned orbit this coverage had a radius
of 1060 kilometers lowering the altitude
of a satellite decreases the area can
cover but also decreases the latency
this is particularly noticeable for
typical communication satellites
operating in geostationary orbit at an
altitude of 36,000 kilometers the time
it takes data to travel up to the
satellite and back down travelling at
the speed of light is around 240
milliseconds 369 percent slower than our
subsea cable
however since StarLink is intending to
operate at a much lower altitude the up
and down like theoretical latency could
be as low as 3.6 milliseconds this is
why SpaceX needs so many satellites in
their constellation in order to provide
worldwide coverage each individual
Starling satellite has four phased array
antenna located here here here and here
this directional beam was an essential
part of SpaceX's FCC approval
application as thousands of satellites
broadcasting undirected radio waves
would cause significant amounts of
interference with other communication
methods once that data is received by
one Starling satellite it can begin to
transmit that information between
satellites using lasers each time we hop
from satellites there will be a small
delay as the laser light is converted to
an electric signal and back again but it
is too minuscule to consider things get
tricky here with using lasers as we need
to accurately hit the receiver on
neighboring satellites to transmit that
data let's look at space X's proposed
constellation to see how this will work
SpaceX is first phase of one side
584 satellites will occupy 24 orbital
plates with 66 satellites in each plane
inclined at 53 degrees this will look
something like this
communications between neighboring
satellites in the same orbital plane is
relatively simple as these satellites
will remain in relatively stable
positions in relation to each other this
gives us a solid line of communication
along a single orbital plane but in many
cases a single orbital plane will not
connect two locations so we need to be
able to transfer information between
these planes too this requires precise
tracking as the satellites traveling in
neighboring orbital planes are
travelling incredibly quickly and will
come in and out of view this means the
sterling satellite will need to switch
to a new satellite in the network this
can take time the best figure I could
find is about a minute for the European
Space Agency's data relay satellite
system which is a currently operating
geostationary Internet constellation
designed to serve European imaging
satellites and other time critical
applications such as serving emergency
forces in remote areas like those
fighting forest fires StarLink may be
faster but it won't be instantaneous and
thus it has five optical communication
systems onboard to maintain a steady
connection to four satellites at all
times if we now use this system
transmitting from New York to London and
back with the shortest path possible
using the speed of light in a vacuum as
air transfer speed we can achieve a
latency as low as 43 milliseconds even
if we took the shortest route possible
with an optic fiber which does not exist
this would take about 55 milliseconds a
28 percent decrease in speed the actual
current returned trip time for your
average Joe is about 76 milliseconds as
we saw earlier a 77% decrease in speed
this is a huge deal for the two
financial markets working out of these
cities with millions of dollars being
moved in fractions of a second having a
lower latency would provide a massive
advantage in capitalizing on price
swings in fact it wouldn't be the first
time a communications company has made a
massive investment to
specifically served these groups the
Hibernian Express cable is a privately
owned optic cable that is currently the
lowest latency connection between the NY
for data center in Syracuse New Jersey
and the LD for data center in Slough
England at just fifty nine point nine
five milliseconds thirty nine point four
percent slower than our best time with
StarLink the previous best time was held
by the AC one cable at sixty five
milliseconds at a cost of three hundred
million dollars this five millisecond
increase in speed was justified to just
connect across the Atlantic
imagine how much these time sensitive
industries will be willing to pay for a
17 millisecond increase in speed it
becomes even more valuable when you
realize this time differential increases
with increased transmission distance New
York to London is a relatively short
distance the improvements would be even
more pronounced for a London to
Singapore transmission for every
additional kilometre we travel the
potential gains and speed increase
rapidly but SpaceX earned just planning
on serving the superfast internet to
some customers they primarily advertised
the system as a way to connect every
human on this planet to the Internet and
they should have plenty of bandwidth
left over to serve these people although
the Internet has been one of the fastest
growing technologies in human history by
the end of 2019 more than half the
world's population will still be offline
users will connect to this Internet
using a stirling terminal which will
cost around $200 each
but this will still be far outside the
purchasing power of money third world
citizens but it's a start and vastly
cheaper than similar currently available
receivers like the climb meta version at
a price of $30,000 Elon Musk says that
these will be flat enough to fit onto
the roof of a car and other vehicles
like ships and aeroplanes
this will allow Starling to compete with
traditional internet providers it's
estimated that moving the u.s. from a 4G
to a 5g wireless connection will cost
around 150 billion in fiber optic
cabling alone over the next seven years
the SpaceX plan to complete their entire
stirling project for as little as 10
bill
each Starling satellite cost around 300
thousand which is already a massive
cutting cost for communication
satellites SpaceX are also saving on
launch costs as they are launching on
their own Falcon 9 rocket
something no other satellite
manufacturer has if everything goes to
plan StarLink is estimated to generate
30 billion to 50 billion in revenue each
year on the back of premium stock
exchange memberships demolishing the
current annual revenue of around 3
billion and this is a vital part of Elon
Musk's long-term goals the money
generated from StarLink will mean SpaceX
will have vastly more funding the NASA
which could go on to fund research and
development of new rockets and the
technologies needed to monetize lunar
and Martian colonies for now the project
is simply aiming to connect the world
even more and potentially open avenues
for education for third world countries
that do not have adequate connections to
the Internet widely available Internet
will help solve this problem and
platforms like brilliant have taken
great steps to remedy this through their
high quality interactive math and
science learning courses brilliant has
helped thousands of users realize their
potential in math and science and it's
stories like this why I am proud to
promote brilliant every month they have
a huge number of courses that will allow
you to educate yourself from
foundational math courses the course is
tailored for you to ace the American
mathematics competition with others
geared for computer science and physics
brilliant recently introduced a new
feature called daily challenges which
will present you with interesting
scientific and mathematical problems to
test your brain every day if I have
inspired you and you want to educate
yourself then go to brilliant org ford
slash real engineering and sign up for
free and the first 500 people to go to
that link will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription so you can get full
access to all their courses as well as
their entire daily challenges archive as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below
[Music]
you